yeah Martin Luther King to be the number
one person I you know it's just so
amazing that guy you know and I wish she
was alive today because I wanted to get
to his head and just find out what he
was thinking when he said things so when
he you know when to leave him a protest
or what have you so he was such an
amazing guy and I you know I think he's
influenced my life a lot and he will be
the number one person I want to talk
with you know I love Mandela also these
are just incredible guys that come once
in a while you know maybe Obama would be
the next one so we'll see but you know
you don't get a lot of these people you
know who you can look up to as mentors
you know you know two great icons like
that and and unfortunately some of these
big icons there's always strategy
surrounding them you know and I'm not
I've never been able to to understand
why you know must you have a tragedy for
someone to be such a great icon you know
but yeah
you